موجز الاخبار اهلا بكم قالت القوات
الاوكرانيه انها صدقت محاولات روسيه
للتقدم في مدينه باخمت وقرب مواقع في بلده
بنت جنوب شرق المدينه وقد نفذ قيادات
ميدانيه اوكرانيه للجزيره ان تكون القوات
الروسيه قد حققت تقدم في بخبط من جهتها
نشرت وسائل الاعلام روسيه صورا جديده قالت
انها لقوات شركه فاجنر العسكريه الروسيه
الخاصه داخل سوليدار مؤكده سيطرتها على
كامل المدينه
وقال الرئيس الروسي ان العمليه العسكريه
في اوكرانيا تسير بشكل ايجابي ووفقا الخطط
العسكريه لوزاره الدفاع وهيئه الاركان
[موسيقى]
قال الامين العام للنيتو ان دول غربيه
سترسل شحنات اضافيه من الاسلحه الثقيله
لكيف واضاف يانسن بيرجعنا المرحله الحاليه
من الحرب حاسمه ويجب ارسال الاسلحه التي
تحقق لاوكرانيا النصر
قتلت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في
الفلسطينيين اعزل القرب بلده سلواد شرقي
مدينه رام الله وذلك من المسافه الصفر بعد
الاعتداء عليه بالضرب وظهر مقطع فيديو
لحظه اطلاق النار على الشهيد احمد كحله
وقالت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه ان الشهيد
استشهد بعد اصابته برصاصه في عنقه
شهدت بلده يعبد جنوب غرب مدينه جنين
مواجهات تخللتها اشتباكات مسلحه بين
مقاومين فلسطينيين وقوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي التي اقتحمت البلده لكن لم
يبلغ عن وقوع اصابات في الجانبين واكد
شهود عيان انسحاب قوات الاحتلال من البلده
افاد جهود عيان بان مسلحين فلسطينيين
اطلقوا النار على حافله للمستوطنين قرب
بلده حلحول شمال الخليل ثم انسحبوا من
المكان وقال جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيليين
الحافله تعرضت لاضرار جراء اصابتها بعده
اعيره ناريه دون وقوع خسائر بشريه ودفعت
قوات الاحتلال بتعزيزات الى المنطقه وشنت
حمله اعتقالات وباشرت عمليه تمشيط واسعه
اقترح اتحاد الشغل في تونس مناقشه
انتخابات الرئاسيه مبكره وتعديل الدستور
ضمن مبادره لحل ازمه يتم بلورتها مع عدد
من قوه المجتمع المدني وحذر الامين العام
المساعد للاتحاد العام لشغل من الانتفاضه
بسبب تفقير الشعب جراء ما وصفه بخيارات
وسياسات غير شعبيه للحكومات المتعاقبه
ياتي ذلك وسط انتقادات لصمت الرئاسه عن
مبادره المجتمع المدني
اعلن رئيس هيئه الانتخابات التونسيه ان
الدوره الثانيه من الانتخابات التشريعيه
سيجرى في التاسع والعشرين من يناير رجال
واضاف ابو عسكر في مؤتمر صحفيين بالعاصمه
تونس ان الهيئه اكملت الاستعدادات
اللوجستيه اللازمه لاجراء الانتخابات
اجتمع اعضاء اللجنه العسكريه المشتركه
خمسه زائد خمسه الممثلون عن شرق ليبيا
وغربها بمقر اللجنه في سيرتي لمناقشه
اليات خروج القوات الاجنبيه والمرتزقه من
ليبيا وبكر المصدر ان اللجنه ستحسم مساله
تشكيل قوه مشتركه من حكومه الوحده الوطنيه
وقوات اللواء المتقاعد خليفه حفتر لتامين
مناطق التماس بين طرفين
قالت مصادر الليبيه للجزيره الى مديره
وكاله المخابرات المركزيه الامريكيه
ويليامبرز حذر خلال اللقائه لواء المتقاعد
خليفه حفتر في بنغازي من المساج بموانئ
النفطي وحقوله وتصديره
ختام الموجز في امان الله
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]